[Applause]
so in addition to being on this show
tarek davis is also a cast member of the
hit broadway show freestyle love supreme
print
freestyle love supreme is a totally
improvised rap show that is running
ratna
at the booth theater in new york city
and since they're our neighbors down the
street i invited them over to play one
of their improv games for us how does
that sound
great
please welcome anthony two-touch vanessa
alley
kayla kyler jose milady arthur the
geniuses louis and derek turtis hardaway
davis
okay so on their way into our studio
today our audience wrote down a bunch of
suggestions on little pieces of paper
and we put them all in this bucket
anthony and tarik are now going to
perform an entirely 100 improvised
freestyle wrap for you using those
suggestions now folks they have not seen
these suggestions before the first time
they will hear them is while they are
rapping can you believe that i cannot
audience are you ready
kayla
kayla are you ready
[Applause]
hold on to your butts here we go
all right all right
your first word is vacation okay
i gotta leave this job you know
hesitation i'm trying to get there yo my
vacation where i'm gonna go looking for
a place to chill here we go mayo gotta
leave work on my kill somebody ah next
word superhero all right yeah
look at me i'm leo i see the ones and
zeroes i'm fighting the matrix flying
high like superhero uh here we go yo i
don't eat a cape because yo i'm about to
break out of this machine escape
pungent
okay
um all right yo the word be pungent i
think of that and yo i'm not bugging but
yo it's got me uh looking for some
hugging because right here yo this room
be buggin
next word hungry ah man yo let me tell
you something see right now yo i'm
monstrous hungry i can eat a big mac i
can eat a large fry because right now
man yo i gotta feed the little guy it's
my stomach
last word
pumpkins uh
got that beat moving grooving getting
stumping yeah halloween season i'm like
a pumpkin i'm coming through everybody
yeah we thumping we rumping we doing
this yeah let me tell you something i'm
about to grab the mic and throw it away
here we go cause two touches gonna take
my place i'm gonna hit him with some
rhymes yo he is sublime you ready for
your first word you ready for your first
rhyme yeah all right
bodega huh
yeah go to the corner what what can i
say oh a bueno diaz a welcome to the
bodega yeah i'm just gonna get there in
harlem's kitchen or maybe you could have
me in the ill position with your country
club lemonade in the back yeah thank you
for running that bodega shack
excited oh i'm so happy and glad and
yeah we just might we're fighting these
feelings that we have but no i'll be
excited cause we out once again you got
vaccinated we're so goddamn bad that you
made it
[Music]
quintessential
oh my gosh how do i do this it feels
elemental when it's quintessential it's
the essence yeah like a black magazine
all right everybody my credit score is
good and yes i apologize because i often
should
mama
yeah i'm just thinking about that winter
garden scenery like mamma mia or cats
yeah that's the greenery you want to be
back to everything i don't even
understand the team is freestyling yes
we do that love supreme last words
sunshine
i got sunshine on a cloudy day and
everybody's wanna say that why they go
to out to 30 rock because we want to
play with all these people up on stage
and yes we do a monopoly all right yeah
these people we always get on top of
these oh my gosh
thank you so much to freestyle love
supreme give them a round of applause we
love them
and please go see their fantastic show
on broadway at the booth theater
[Music]
you